[Musique]
parce que le Tour de France doit rester
une fête ou que ce qui est politique
racisme tout qu'est-ce qui doit pas se
voir on est face
si on en a une sur la route vous voyez
un siège qui a des familles avec des
enfants tout ça c'est pas beau c'est pas
c'est pas une belle image ça représente
un peu le tour de France on m'appelle
fin vulgarité l'effaceurs de [__]
du jeu sur le Tour de France ma fonction
c'est d'effacer des graffitis les sexes
des messages politiques racisme et en
plus en sécurisé les routes un caca qui
est pas mal mis une bonne rôle leur
temps en mettre une sangle là ça descend
vraiment là c'est bon non
on fait ça tous les étapes
où les messages
raciales tout ça on nettoie
bonjour ça reverra tout à l'heure je
remonte après il y a pas de problème
allez
je pourrais continuer des années à faire
je ferai ça des années je suis à la
retraite et je continue à travailler
parce que j'adore ça je fais le tour de
France et je fais Paris rouba aussi mais
bon avant il faut savoir que je
travaillais
avec des boulevards des allongés vous
allez me dire c'est quoi le boulevard
des allongés la justice croque-mort et
maintenant je travaille avec des bons
vivants là ça me plaît
[Applaudissements]
on doit tous ces gens là sur le côté qui
attendent pour voir la caravane passer
les coureurs passés là on est dans
l'ambiance là c'est l'ambiance dure deux
fois
la majorité des messages pour voir que
tu dois effacer
politique comme beaucoup de messages
politiques c'est le premier Macron pour
vous de sexe quand même
ça dépend les endroits
après j'ai fasse pas bêtement les
messages encouragement je les laisse
quand même on efface pas tout il y en a
beaucoup qui me connaissent j'ai quand
même signé deux autographes dans ma vie
et puis j'ai pris trois on m'a pris
trois fois en photo avec les gens qui
voulaient te prendre en photo avec moi
on m'a toujours dit encore pour
l'instant on me dit ah bah si tu peux
encore le faire un ou deux ans et
peut-être plus c'est la santé qui manque
trop peut-être ou bien ou bien il y aura
peut-être plus rien à effacer sur les
routes mais ça j'y crois pas j'y crois
pas non non il y aura toujours un petit
sexe ou un petit message politique à
effacer je pense